[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna yo-yo ma no CSUN ha ha
listen I'm calm you the lungs and hello
Lamia I'm Hilah want me here now huh you
can enroll by doing at heart just like
announcement for all guests who have
just arrived we are here for our kind of
cooperation the whole media against that
was in front of the stage so please
refrain kindly refrain from using phones
to take pictures or to do live during
conference please be seated during
conference thank you
[Music]
[Music]
parlez francais buongiorno Kanaka
teacher Han Ji na ma
Kenyatta pom Tamika diver bahay na
Tanaka
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] logic team na na ko dekha and
their fancy from here from the right is
coach a for this audience don't need not
happen not be huh and the first father
is not a tea no tea time do I know I
don't have and followed by add only the
second seat the third seat actually
followed by a duel I'm doing too much it
be - yaha and the first one is a SIA is
a psychologist the way you know by now
and saku-dono
today go Dan can give let me like Omega
be like Amina okay I can do something
like amongst the Wonder - okay the names
- you're lying good
[Music]
okay
wanna see no add nakaka minam add me no
add by are
happening for me
no matter
okay Baba no Mac huh that's mark no not
have a talk I look I'm don't be ha
followed by do you last time - I know ha
ha
and next two beauties dawn
and the back benches will be taken by
the seals
no no huh nice at that end
no maker and a big no-no what ha a note
and then the doctor no make other big
solid but make their number and done
floppy dinner home and ended up with
pole
when a copepod car and the one that that
she's pointing is tightened title will
be seated or sitting there
[Music]
nom nom tienen la nina ha been on our
team oppa nakata unity mio can Kaplan
will convene with an AHA lock open 20
launch Andrea make an aha
t pencil young and good power could man
who perform that ha ha ok I know on your
left are the the teammates the Volvo
team mates of the boys and also the
classmates of the boys and with the
yellow shirts we have behind the boys
the boys
yeah that's it
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello name Sam
Sam see
you
you
[Music]
Oh up in one Tila like one draw call la
la la patte one kappa but canh to pi
systems to operation crisis taking place
there were divers there were doctors the
media everyone involved worked together
so many volunteers and it was successful
operation there was a loss of course
unfortunately we lost one a former Navy
SEAL during the operation who came out
of retirement to help in the rescue
mission he was known as die Sam name is
in this position now care was lieutenant
commander Samana by everyone to be a
true
regarding the activity on 13 okay kids
who were asking with his majesty the
king of it offered okay press ins and
also a shirts and also on hats
okay so 13 kids and this was to provide
moral support to the team for them to
continue on after this very challenging
and difficult ordeal that they had to
face and right now there is activity
taking place they are again ready to
send the 13 members of the robot enemy
team back home there are so many media
members as you can see on the screen
right now and they are ready to meet
with all 13 members of the mobile enemy
team up close and personal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so someone is we tune it with the team
ah
Saddam who take your call
they can so much awesome when Jordan
Carter canang when children socata
canang comma Y come time come check up
letting me come come come no you cannot
pad not Ethiopia let you tap hello
panting hip-hop what can I do can go
wrong
oh I'm not yet from the posterior so a
media okay are blocked okay to get
different answers okay I'm due to the
protocol
okay by the champ I a Garvin and his
team so today we will listen together
okay on maybe that feelings and also
other questions from a science
so mr. so she was saying that the media
are all there together they would like
to speak with the members of the team to
answer all the questions that not just
the time of it also before me they may
have everyone just anyone around the
world interested in knowing he invited
the media to some questions up to the
doctors to have the doctors review the
questions for so today and this will be
handed off to mr. so to tell you when we
can ask the team members we're now going
to watch a video clip that the 13
members put together question will go to
and so he will tell us more about you
know the activity from past period of
time and there was the situation and
they came out of here last night okay
we're all melty okay what over 100 so
what you're seeing what you saw earlier
the boys playing football just now that
was to show that they are healthy again
and on the video this is something
that's been taking place since a couple
of days ago the hospital staff have been
busy helping the boy helping to
rehabilitate them and bring them to good
spirits
and though they have faced a crisis they
are truly very strong in the mental
activity in order to give a mental
support okay full on survivors and you
see the doctors and the nurses passing
on their love to the kids ready to go
home they're ready to go back to society
be part of the society your care your
support help them to regain their
confidence back it's when they look back
they will see what have been through but
they have been through and enjoyed the
experience every member have developed
the more confidence and face their
situation bravely I can put my feeling
in word but we as people in the
experience in the cave I would hope that
we will build up our friendship we would
like to go home so please stand up and
go back to sit with sit with your
parents the psychiatrist confirmed that
they every member of the ball team y-bar
team is healthy and ready to go back so
that they can be
and leaving their only the average
health emotionally as well as physically
they are ready we have the had had these
times and times again that healthy hold
up your two fingers I would like to hear
from the psychiatrist okay I confirm
that the healthy and ready to their life
back even while they were in the case I
would like to know why I would like to
know they didn't have why they were in
the case why tell me I have by my
observation why they I was with them in
the cave after after they have food and
they start from did not talk much but I
have to have food like in their energy
and they they were talking about what
we'll do if the when they go out of the
cave and they told they're touching each
other or what kind of food would they be
eating what kind of activity they will
be doing in the future
I confirm that they are ready to face
life out normal life okay but dr. Patel
one had observed assessment do do the
assessment emotional
from a consultation and from the
psychiatrist's section I have found have
found the that the team member of the
warp 5 bye
why boy and I I do confirm after the
assessment each individual and come up
to the conclusion that there is no
problem to be worried about I have
talked and have found that they are
ready there there are many question that
I have received and the psychiatrist
already assess the question I would
allow all listen question yes I talked
to the member of my wife boy I have
found that they they are fine physic by
physically as well as emotionally well
they they have hope that they would
would be able to get out and leave back
in the leaf back in their formally
family and the likelihood of being I
[Music]
believe that you you will be be contact
with the member the both are returned
back home and I would like to welcome
the doctor too
our province and do the follow-up after
the team member returned home is that
correct
I agree that this rescue mission is
international and we work in a team they
are the hospital the mental health and
the matter of this team we are working
together in order to look after these
children as well as we can the the
member of the team is Anais and behaved
very well the nice that they're cute I
like them very much I am happy to live
with them I am sorry I'm happy to that
I'm work to work with them and I'm proud
about it I the children the rich from
8-11 is the the age of the child is
range between 11 to 17 from the
assessment they develop according to the
growth of their age thus they have the
strength some sometimes we after we did
the assessment we have realized that we
gained so much from talking to every
member of the wild boar let's introduce
now please
preaching please not please we would
like to see whether you still healthy
my name is egg back right back I'm coach
greeting my pawns
my nickname is T my position is middle
creating a dune Saban back right upper
back right Janine be Boone my name my
name is Dan I play right left left side
left right
I am 11 years old reading my name is
Hong Kong
my name is Mack I said I play in the
center and right back and right it is 13
my name is Bill I sent her and gold
greeting do my name is nick name down
I'm playing in the front position my
name is Knight
my position is back and bold with my
name is my name is Nick my name is my
position is center
greeting my name is note my eye my
position is right and left my my name is
Mick I play in the center position
waiting my nickname
Eastern play in the center position
greeting my name's Holmes i won
my name is pong I play at the left wing
you see stay with the children for nine
nine days my name is T the day sweats
want it upon you my name is Tom greeting
my name is Mike this is Navy SEAL member
who say answer when the answer to the
question how many member and someone
said 13 and this is a person tell me
when where were you and how did you see
the diver and how would you spend the
question and answer right away did you
think they'd do what tell me what
happened before prior to did
my name is adoun and can you speaking it
yes a little
the event took place in the evening we
were play on the rock and I heard noises
and I said please everyone be quiet I
heard someone talking and I wasn't sure
whether it was right or dream so we
listened and it have realized that it's
real and and when I was I was shocked
and asked Mik Mik show to yourself Mik
Mik why do you tell me to you tell me to
go down because Mick has the torch
go ahead Nick quick let them let them
see that they're here okay I said me was
Mick was afraid the then make words
affair so I grab the torch for me and
then I am him he came down and then I
child I picked him I said hello
umm it's the time that they came as if
came up from the surface and I greet and
I asked her hello
is there anyone around here i I thought
he was Thai people but they it was not
after they came up from the surface on
the water I was shocked
if that person is an English I did not
know what to talk and I said hello
something like that he said they said
hello and I said hello back I it's just
a miracle that happened but I did not
know how to answer when he'd talk
he took me long time to answer that
person back he that's
and he surfaced he asked how are you and
I was frightened and I said can I help
you he said no no no you just go up and
then when I went up I asked how many of
you and I asked and we we have 13 and he
said he's brilliant
my grandma Berlin and he because that
diver was excited that they are all 13
people at some food
someone said parody lady course said why
to tell us by sport to a foreign person
I couldn't speak English bill wouldn't
an interpreter interpret view when they
talk fill it on talking who can speak
English and do interpret and is there
anyone interpret do interpret and and
they said quick quick quick do it quick
and what what else I couldn't I couldn't
listen I couldn't follow calm down calm
down
I told thee I told pity that calm down
said to PT p they tell you come down
from that we all were excited about it
it's bring us hope and in 10 days the
hope just raise rice up
really I said that the driver said to me
go up a high come down when I come down
yeah he asked how many Dave people and
all of you who were staying in the cave
if my memory saved me life the question
was how many days in the in the cave or
something like that I said 10 it's he's
my my brain was working slow when I was
studying math and English and I forgot
it so take me so slow someone said you
who chew you know someone's someone
shout hungry hungry hungry but it was
the time that we have our heart burst
and happy it was the first time that we
can say - after that they say to
themselves that oh there's hope now have
you seen the football have you seen the
football match is it life life good what
do you think is it fun oh so so very
good and at that night I saw the voice
of cheer cheering whoo who made the the
loudest night tell tell us what was
excitement who do you who did you want
to win then which year the French at the
beginning it wasn't that I didn't feel
that fun but when I saw the
the geekman who I like when then I
became so excited why do you like him I
like him because he's gone many girls
did did the coach say quite weird that's
why and if if not you they they will not
allow us to watch football
no no because the doctor was there and
big Viera we will allow course for the
French to Croatia you wash life it was
the first time that we were able to
watch football after we came out from
the cave I would like to ask why did you
go to the cave who will ask answer the
coach would answer the question
the question we were we were asking and
talking when what what can we do in for
the team-building then someone suggest
that I would like to go lambda Tom
looong case and then we plan then then
we shoot go up to the summit of the
dough I - and do the prep prep so we we
will play football before we go to the
cave we played them they have a match
after we'd finish the game then we walk
to the the case to have to survey what
was in the case
have you been has anyone been there
before no no no one Oaks except me that
cave at that time it was it was deep it
was long it the previous time and um me
and I fought and playing we went in into
that case at that time it had happened
at the triangle that we we went we saw
the water but it wasn't deep then I went
in and I said I said if you do you want
to go in because we have one hour
because we have to go in and out because
by five o'clock because that is going to
send them to two tutorial at five
o'clock
is there anyone surveyed birthday no no
no I said today is my birthday but five
five o'clock I have to be at home
because my my parent prepared the
birthday party for me then then we did
when we entered the case we we came we
went through the case and on the wane on
the way back I after the triangle and we
arrived back to the Laplace down and
that's water and I asked if you want to
explore you we have to swim if you want
to go you have to swim they said
I am going to explore before we ha but
whether it is deep and what kind of
thing that we will face is that is
everyone able to swim yes everyone can
swim because I it was in my training
program ever because every Saturday
after it's the football we would take
them to swimming lesson at that time
[Music]
swim swim first
they said it the water is not the deep I
am at the cha now please come then
people go going ahead of time and to
shake the big boy will go first and when
they reach there then then I have
realized that okay we can go ahead but
there's more water and and we discussed
whether is there anyone is there anyone
who want to carry on and then I check is
longer than the time that we supposed to
be I then we check with nothing nothing
he said it's longer than an hour so
let's go back then we come back later
and then every everyone swam back and
then walk like no more walk back like
normal we arrive at that triangle be you
said we will charge we water here paddle
here and someone said are we lost a what
and I said no no because there's only
one root then we are going we are
explore to whether this is the right way
the same way
that becoming then the dye and doing
whole rope and I hold the rope I have
the rope to if I check two times it
means that I can escape if there is if I
check to the rope to turn then check it
means that I can return and and I get in
I realized that it's sandy at the back
and the book and up upward was rock and
everyone was pulling the rope and I
realized that we can we couldn't return
about this route and at that time what
what do you feel what do you feel would
be I would be soil at my my mother
what do you think maybe we shouldn't we
shouldn't be lost I am sure we could be
able to go back I was thinking that that
we would be able to get out it was that
because I'm sure that we have oxygen
what did you think at that
and my calm down I did not feel
frightened I told everyone be courage do
not lose hope the reason why you would
check the rope because we could not hear
each other right or to cover and the
water people is in the water no matter
what kind of the other if we recheck two
times and everyone is hold pooling and I
realize we could not go out so we have
to find and at the root and I tell
everyone that how can we get out oh
let's dig so that too much for coming we
said let's go on fine
Rock what time is it it is about five
o'clock we reject carry on [ __ ] dig
and dig and the water have did not
change that they said they said we
should find place to sleep is that back
yah
it's after six o'clock so we agree let's
go and find the place to sleep I said do
dude do not be afraid it's it's like a
loti hide i so but now let's go and find
a place to sleep
do you have any food we I we didn't
prepare anything because we already had
something to eat at the football ground
after that we move from the triangle
section about 200 meter we there's a
feel and there's water water drip from
the app that I told I told everyone that
let's be near to the water let's sleep
find a place to sleep but before we go
to bed because we go to sleep and then
let's apply before we go to sleep and
then we pray at that time how do you
feel I we didn't feel afraid why do you
think that you might be able to go out I
I think that the tie will be low and
someone the officer would come and find
us how do you want to plan a survival I
mean I lead all the young people to find
the escape route route I look I wash the
time and find water to drink how do you
find the drinking water oh it's from the
water water that drip from the rock at
the water is clean it's like another
water only water weed we have no food no
food all the time that you were in the
cave when you the next day what do you
plan to find something to eat we only
drink water did you start to feel that
your body is getting weak at the
beginning first they know about 2 days 2
days later
then we start to feel someone coach said
stay still so that you use less energy
and use a light touch sparingly and
anyone who has a torch keep and preserve
the energy how long did you stay there
keep keep the energy until the the diver
came the second day ten days later
during those time is there anyone who
feel a fatigue and and and really I said
we have to do something every is
everyone who feel that of we felt
everyone felt fatigued and less
low-energy
what
have no it hungry when you're very
hungry
I didn't then I don't think a food it
will make me feel more happy
I would I would like to have fried rice
and pick on long paste chili paste did
you feel I will drink water in order to
make me feel full what did you do when
you have no time dig the hole at the
back of the cave are you we use rock we
what were able to dig about three for me
far why do you do that that's the way I
would like to find a new route to get
now on the fourth or fifth day we were
thinking that we have to find the new
route whether to the front or the back
and be pure and other used to used to
camp in here and at the root at the back
but it's a long distance I asked them
would you like to take a risk and time
to try that route if it's only one
chance you don't if you find we don't
find the route you we will be in
dangerous so we discuss what to do
there's two choice here or a wait for
try to carry on and wait for the
the rescuer and then we heard water the
sound of water
and then we saw we saw we saw water we
then I at numbers I've known we said I
said please go up to the highest place
and we wait for more than an hour the
water race rise up about three meet
meters and have you heard and is falling
rent no later on meeting at the top at
the bottom we there's no choice we have
to wait further and rescue team and
Detroit is dick and that the the the
tunnel at least he can do something
instead of just wait and doing nothing
and so we went up there and dick we
Tecton when when one gets tired and
other will go until the night with yes
we'd but you you used so much energy we
what we did was we eat we drink water
until before we go digging the case then
we take her like that in the evening the
water has turned nice and be able to
drink
English I said the doctor and the driver
arrived and tried to meet the group
after you realize that and the boy were
met and the SEAL team from the net hi
Navy dive - - to be with them and I four
of us stay with them and try to help
them to regain energy and try to plan
the route of rescued one thing that I
didn't I didn't think that that the
route the return route will be difficult
at the beginning I was thinking the king
the whole of the the whole up on the
roof of the Cape will be better the high
of the water
what I of the water we wait for it to go
to be low tie this to the second option
is the diver foreign driver bought us
food for both bora food for for the
people for the team and use the diving
gear to rescued and we we discuss of the
plan whether we the team have enough
energy to dies that long distant and
then we plan this is the plan of rescue
that have
were done before these are the three
with the children whatever that you were
there children
Oh what did you do he he where and where
did you do that because it suit of his
suit is what and he did not wear other
under underwear and he used the boy to
cover what do you think it's it's funny
and firstly the this mission the
supervisor at LCL said that if you do
not find the children do not return I've
walked a lot because I did not put the
helmet so that my head was hit by those
rock I have have realized in my heart I
have said to myself that I have to
succeed and find and rescue these
children when I arrived then I tried to
assess their emotional
you are you okay oh yeah then after what
after I've met them and realized that
they I realized that they are help happy
and healthy I have fought in in my self
I have medicine and forth and torch and
wetsuit
but when I arrived there I give I took
all those and give those give those away
I I have to lay some foundation
foundation to be late because in there
in the ground of the cave its soil is
sand and wet and I kept I kept the I
gave those foil to the children to sit
and some of them I just wrap around my
body very sexy-looking
all right that you spend with the
wild-boar team 9 day that there would be
friendship and relationship and
activities what did you do what how did
you play that yes chess game chess game
and king of is a king of kefir why you
lose I don't know and I I remember
try to remember a play play chess game
is the inlet
angle section Oh what is what kind of
you have what I do memory memory that
you have about opening about seals it's
good rhythm chip it's like family and
Leave leave together like family we eat
together we sleep together have a other
please go ahead okay what is your
opinion about still I feel too biter
it's like my father like like my father
because he better call me by the name of
son I felt great glad because he because
people find activity for us to play and
tell us stories do you stay with
children nine days is your memory doctor
because I can see that that's one
between you and the children
yeah family we asked you we feel close
to everyone i I feel that everyone have
good relationship and close get close to
each other we check each other we share
food and the plan and how to how the
security and the safety and the
well-being of the children we that's our
aim and that a plan as they look they
look like in the same they look like the
same age of machine so we treat each
other like family it's good
but we are sad because we lost me sad
another thing is it I'm I'm I'm Tosh
that some salmon cook none sacrifice his
life for the well-being and for the
safety of us all everyone when knows
when know that one person sacrifice his
life to us one person and we were truck
at the beginning and we were sad it's
like we are the cause of that person's
dipped his have we felt that that the
last of feel for the loss of
kamongo nuns family because he died for
us
Oh Sam Coonan but so we we have this
have this idea that we are going to
express our feeling to Sam's family we
read what you write on that photo please
the youngest one start to really read
loudly please regrettable that you
passed away may you be in peace
and thank you very much for sacrificing
your life and I feel sorry for to the
your family with all of my heart and
bead sank thank you very much to the Sam
lon and the everyone member of the
family I wished I wish you were at a
good place
thank you very much for my from the
bottom of my heart from a pond
whatever happened all of the experience
that they had either shocked or sad
everyone in the society would remember
this event this lesson for every one of
the wild-boar team please as the lesson
that I've read it that I have is it
I am so thankful for the support and
care to if to everyone who support us I
will use my life with careful and use
this experience I will use my life with
care and consideration
I will think twice before I do anything
whether it's gonna be the effect for the
fair an effect to the other the
experience I have learned many things
about this peril and you have made up
your mind to do what to do with your
life I will be a good person in in the
community
I asked me I think that I would be more
careful what the the unforeseen able
incidents that is taking place in my
life this this experience tell me that I
have to be more careful considerate I
will be more aware of the consequence of
my action at this time as of now I will
use and spend my life carefully and
wisely before we go to into the case do
you have a dream after when you get out
of it like that cave I will change I
won't change my dream is going to let I
want to be a professional football
player
this experience is affect you in in what
way
yeah there is for this X this experience
make me stronger experience what do you
learn from this experience is the
biggest in in my life
I have learned the values in mind of my
life this experience can cost me to be
patient and strong and do not lose hope
I will go Harry in my dream that I would
like to to be a football player
and I'd like to join see your team
I would like to be professional football
player and still yes both can be can I
learn and possible and be able to find
good job and became professional
football I would like to become a
professional football and want to be a
seal I want to because I why do you want
to be in a situation because I want to
help you I don't think I can't think
what what do I want to be I just want to
carry on study and graduate I would like
to go and study high as high as possible
and I would like to become professional
footballer
I would like to graduate as high as
possible and become a football player
you know Julian to study and graduate
high and became one of the national
football team if I ask you to go to the
Cape again do you want to go if anyone
asked me I don't think I know but the P
the people in in the team asked me to be
guide ok I can lead to the front of the
cape and the rest you could go no I
don't want to go back to the cave
the the most the most thing that you
worry is that you can't do the homework
yet do you have not met tisha
why do you worry about it
because there's a lot of homework what
will you do there's a when didn't took
place and I will have to put something
in place on behalf of the government it
is important and a big event in in the
CAF you have people look after you in
school in school teacher look after you
in hospital to look after you and the
group of people are going to look up to
you according to the children's law this
tariff is a person who will look after
you lead the life and the health service
will look after you as well
whatever happen when you return home
there's a group of support organization
well we will look after you at your
community at your village with we will
plan have a meeting and plan and those
[Music]
community people would the community
support people would write the report
and report me tonight when you go home
what would you like to
the first thing did you have what did
you eat did you resign oh I was able to
eat everything you desire
bread chocolate um basil
rice I already ate rice soup I was
dreaming in in the cave night according
to talk to the the plan to rescue mark
is one of the six people that had we at
first day we have small masks so the
mark miss because there is no big mask
this then the the next day still he
missed because of the size of the mask
and then we moved to he moved to the
last day the the night before last
and then he why he was sleep he sleep
talking that I want to eat rice soup
question what is the category of the
rescue who first I was in the meeting of
selecting who okay then we asked said
in a team the team members said whoever
I do mine and then okay the the group of
the people would we who the start from
the people who live near the area first
the people who we were we were thinking
then after when we go back we will do
the bicycle and do the bicycle at home
and then tell the family that prepare
the food as we are going to go there and
have your food over there that's all we
we did not they we did not choose and
pick we vote and we vote and let each
let the vote get let those be picked by
whatever you do choose them like this no
no it's like that they with the head we
didn't you didn't choose by the health
the selection I already talked to dr.
Hurst the ask the children self are good
there's no condition or issue as far as
health in concern and then we plan how
can we go a big boy first
a small boy first it doesn't matter
I don't mind whoever
go first then we come down to whoever
the volunteer who wants you to go up
first
rest your hands what happened if the
people who less slowly and did the Jude
the children do not mind because they
they love they love this you remember
they want to spend time with the seal
member of the the children loves food in
in my opinion the food prepared at all
but this and the to put the vote India
in this wetsuit and zoom-out instrument
I would like to say apologize that I was
a little bit naughty and I didn't listen
that much oh I talked to my mother
when you when you see the mother the
father what would you see I didn't I
didn't say - I would like to apologize
to my mother because I didn't tell my
mother that I am NOT gonna go I'm going
to go to the cave I only want I already
said that I'm going to the football
playing football I I want to apologize
to my mother because I said to my mother
because I didn't tell her the truth if I
tell the truth I know that I wouldn't be
allowed I want to apologize to my mother
that I won't
I didn't I tell her I'm going to go play
ball okay I would like to apologize to
my mother the whole truth because I was
naughty I didn't tell them that I want
to only go practice football didn't tell
them that I'm going to go today
I'd like to apologize to my mother
because I I said I told her that I'm
gonna go and a practice football I would
like to apologize I told my mother the
wrong cave I said I want to go to go to
Tunku Nam not come I think they may go
to the wrong place
because I said I go and play in football
and in the end I am sneaky into the cave
I didn't tell the truth sorry I
apologize to my father mother because I
said to them that i went to play
football and not the cave oh I when I
was in the cave I thought when I go back
I'll be in deep trouble is it is that
what you deserve is a year parents
because I and I want to say I love I
love you Father mother I have realized
that I when they're like that when I
didn't tell the truth I so sad and
disappointed in myself I'm red apologize
to my mother
I know that I know that when I go back
home I'll be big in trouble can you tell
what would you say to your mother in the
cave everyone said and everyone is
saying that if when I go go back me I
would be spoiled by my parent for sure
but if I go before if I come home late
I'll be scolded by them for sure I'll be
in trouble from this the WIPO team
member will be close to each other what
what do you plan to do I have heard from
the parents saying that they that they
should become a monk in order to pay
respect to
Jack saman got none and however long and
we would do all of us we would do
together in a group another like the
last question asked earth psychiatrists
what can what can the children do and
how to ask the to the connection that
should ask the difference I would like
to ask the children to go back to the
side society stay home with clearly
within school like normal I would like
them to feel at home and I do not and I
asked people their father and mother to
not to be judgmental if that the
question that you ask them about what
had happened please be careful if
they're not happy to answer please give
them time
and I have mixed with the member of the
ball team I have realized that I have
they nice children and behave according
to their age they purpose and plan for
their future they have a good parade in
school they con confidence in what
they're doing when they went back to
there and this is a society this is
still good but the development according
to their age maybe not as fast as one
egg is expected when they go back to
live their life normally later they
would be able to adjust back to their
normal and catch up with others in the
society
another question is that there's news
that there before for people who did who
did not have a child
Thai nationality yet I have heard all of
those already sent the application for
that under the proceeding this is the
question and the answer the answer from
the wild-boar team and is they still
have still have happy strength and thank
you very much for your concern
as the mayor of the Chiang Rai Singh
Teague couldn't that to them they're the
successful has came down through the
kindness from the King Rama retained its
through the support and support and pray
from the people all over the world they
care
we that's why I successful
give up
if
I give to every member of the wild-boar
team the the mayor of chiang rai is
going to present this gift
it contained cloth and some other gift
the
you
you
this this interview would answer many
questions from the media that has been
possible if a long time it's the
impressive picture that everyone in the
country care and care and show through
[Music]
mainly mentoree support as well as this
gift after this the LIBOR team member
are going to make their way back home
they will stand and wait there so that
the media will take photo for them
memory and after that we will send you
home and return home to live in their
society in that village as usual okay
the the car is waiting for you in front
okay let's give them a flower to say
goodbye and farewell we send you our
love is going to be accompanied by the
family member as well as AIT the chai
care team from the government
you